ce que nous proposerons par ces
amendements c'est la question de la
neutralité religieuse dans les espaces
d'enseignement de l'université
l'université est une matrice
intellectuelle elle est traversée
aujourd'hui par des mouvements puissants
et destructeur il s'appelle le des
colonialismes le racialisme
l'indigénisme l'intersexualité
[Musique]
le voile comme une obsession pour les
républicains
autre solution pour la société le voile
autre lutte contre le séparatisme le
voile 7 à la fois grossier stigmatisant
inutile vous avez là finalement tout
faux soixante quinze mille morts il y à
3 millions de cas depuis le début et 145
me contaminer supplémentaires depuis la
semaine dernière et nous allons faire
alors nous allons parler du foulard il
ne faudrait pas qu à partir de ce débat
il considère que finalement la question
du voile et la question majeure
[Musique]